how much of the world needs to be
created in the pilot you know that's an
interesting question I would say again
it sort of depends on the show right if
you are writing a genre or a fantasy
show I think
you need to have a sense of what rules
need to absolutely be clear in the pilot
especially if it involves magic or it
involves superpowers or anything like
that
um Executives tend to get a little
mystified by that stuff so clear rules
are very helpful to them even if you
know that you're going to build off on
that and expand on that as you continue
the writing process if it becomes a show
what's absolutely essential in the pilot
that your audience knows and so that's
part of your world building right is
like okay in this if you're writing a
fantasy show let's say that in this uh
Kingdom there's this kind of magic and
in this Kingdom there's this kind of
magic and here's what happens when that
kind of magic you know bumps up against
each other that might be all we need to
know in the pilot but make sure that the
rules of all that are very clear
if you're writing more of a sort of
let's say like a Gray's Anatomy kind of
show it's you really want the characters
to pop you want to be sure that each
character is incredibly distinct
and that we understand what's most
important to you about those characters
from the pilot now you're also creating
a scenario that's going to tell us how
the show works so for instance using
graze as an example interns in a in a
Residency program all the stuff getting
thrown at them and then also
commiserating with each other and
building a relationship with each other
to get through it
easy to understand that's what the show
is but that's all set up in the pilot so
a lot of times what you'll hear is you
know
what's the engine and it really is about
what is helping the audience understand
what to expect every week
so if it's a cop show we understand that
we get a case every week or if it's like
say Bosch on Amazon we maybe have
multiple cases that we're going to
follow through the season and every week
we're going to get more pieces of the
puzzle and we're also going to get all
this personal stuff going on but you
establish that in your pilot like this
is kind of how the show works
so to me that's the most important stuff
and you can always add more to the world
later a lot of times what will happen is
exactly as you know I was telling you in
that other pilot I had to clear some
characters out
sometimes you're like I really want to
introduce this character in The Pilot
because you know they're going to be in
the entire show
but there's just it just is taking up
room in that pilot in a way that's just
a disservice to the story and you have
to be brave enough to pull it out and
hold it
for later in the series because what's
most important is that what the show is
is incredibly clear by the time someone
finishes reading that pilot
they understand the show that you're
trying to make they definitely should
have questions about like well like is
this thing going to pay off and is this
character going to come back and you
know they'll have all kinds of questions
because you want open-ended things you
want there to be Mysteries and and
wondering about how the characters are
going to interact with each other but
how the show will work every single
episode is what you're really trying to
get across on top of your cool
characters and your awesome world and
all that stuff you're painting that
picture for them
how does a writer end a pilot so one of
the first things that I got taught when
I started writing Pilots is certainly in
a in a I'm trying to break into the
business I'm writing writing samples
part of the pilot writing process
you you do not hold anything back story
wise in the pilot so if you're like
all this stuff's gonna happen in the
pilot and then we're gonna open episode
two with like a the Chase and a crash
and this character is going to die I'm
gonna tell you that's the end of your
pilot
right because you want to go big
emotionally or action wise or something
you want it to be like bam at the end of
your pilot so
I wrote one I wrote a pilot where it's
about this political family and
um it's it a hundred percent when you
read it you're like oh this guy's gonna
die he's gonna die he's totally gonna
die and then he doesn't die someone else
dies at the end of Act five and
everybody's so mad at me it's so mad at
me when they read it but then act six is
telling you exactly where we're going
it's like how this what where the family
members are left now now that this the
anchor has fallen away and what's going
to happen and it goes out on this sense
of like oh my God how are they going to
survive this
because you're like how are they going
to survive it that's what you want
someone to say to you right at the end
of that pilot if you're doing a mystery
pilot you know you can
um you can do that thing where we think
we're at the end of the episode it feels
like we've had like this really exciting
fulfilling hour and then like the screen
goes black and then you write you know
but then a door opens and a figure walks
through and we know everything's about
to change out it's like that kind of
stuff that like really makes them want
to know what happens in the next episode
so it can be very it can be description
it can be a line of dialogue it's
whatever it is to you that says gotta
come back next week
and and that's really really true when
you're starting to write them people
want to hold things back because they're
like but then later but then later but
right now there's no later there's only
this if you sell this pilot you can say
hey I'd really love to pull this out and
hold it for later but right now you just
want them to be blown away by your
writing so
I've heard writers say this it has not
really been my experience but it does
happen to a lot of writers that
oftentimes how you think your pilot ends
is really how your pilot begins not a
stance not a rule but sometimes if
people are telling you it just moves too
slow or it just doesn't feel like it has
enough momentum that's a thing to try is
pull the ending up and then right from
that and see what happens
and that's not like bookending it where
you okay that's different not book any
that's literally like that cool amazing
moment that you think is the end of the
pilot might actually be where we need to
start
and then what's in your head is episode
two is really the pilot right so you're
you're using the end of the pilot that
you thought you needed and then kind of
writing episode two
which sometimes really works sometimes
it's like oh right because you were
saving all that cool stuff
and you didn't realize it and now all
the cool stuff from episode two is in
your pilot
are there any other tips you have for
writing a pilot
um maybe we didn't cover you know I
would say this if especially if you're
new to television
um learning to outline is a really
important skill and so if you have not
habitually been a writer who outlines
their material start with the pilots
that you're writing at home
and
um sometimes you can find those examples
again like at the writer's Guild library
or places like that
um I in my book The Writer's room
Survival Guide have a couple of examples
of what an outline can look like to just
help people start to figure out you know
what is that what is this outline thing
I have to do because the more you
practice it at home the less
intimidating it's going to be when a
sure Runners like great can you write me
a 12-page Outline by the end of the week
like you're going to be like sure I can
because you've done it at home right so
it'll be it won't be like a new thing
that's getting dropped on you
and it also just is a good
guide map once you have that outline
writing your pilot it's going to be so
much easier because
as you're loading in like you know
you're like okay and then like now this
is the next scene in the outline
sometimes you can already be like oh
wait I feel like it took us too long to
get here let me go back really quickly
and change this or oh no actually I
think this goes later I'm gonna hold
this scene and do it later as opposed to
you being on the Fly trying to make it
all up as you're going along
so it's a really good
skill to have it's very necessary in
television writing so I would start
practicing it now at home and and
whatever your thing is that you love
while you write I happen to write to
television because I'm a classic
latchkey kid who did her homework with
the TV on
um but music quiet whatever it is
embrace it love it just know that when
you become a TV writer if you have a
boss who says please work in the office
you're going to have to find a way to
make that work for you for me I was
lucky because I came along when
streaming existed so I could still put
TV on and just put my headphones in and
have Friday Night Lights playing in the
background while I wrote so
um but you know whatever how however
you're writing Jam you know works for
you you will have to create a version of
that that works in an office where
people can walk in your door and
interrupt you and do all those things so
just remember that that it's it's a very
different once you become a working TV
writer